after President Trump reportedly
referred to Haiti and African countries
as [ __ ] countries I made a decision
to fly down to Haiti myself to chat with
the Haitian people and make some new
friends well this past weekend I this
past weekend I did just that I just got
back last night I spent four days in
Haiti shooting our Conan in Haiti
special okay 27th 10 o'clock p.m. I
cannot stress enough it is yes it's a
it's a country that has its problems but
it is a beautiful country with
absolutely lovely people and if you
don't mind I'd like to take a moment to
thank the people of Haiti I've asked my
friend Lou Lewis to help me out
Rick thank you so much for doing this so
really appreciate it and here we go I
want to get this message out to the
people of Haiti hello people of Haiti
this is Conan O'Brien Bonjour pepper
sauce and Conan O'Brien Kay thank you
for your generous hospitality during my
visit Messi pututo sweet ally take him
with him yeah I am back in the United
States now gone as soon as I miss the
party
the Haitian food was delicious and
unlike anything I've ever tasted
move out men we're gonna push it from
where apparently he's doing a great job
I also want to thank the Haitian
government for making me feel so welcome
if I said twine you know please aww
[Laughter]
wherever I went I heard beautiful live
music and was often caught up in the
rhythm but my partner by Misaki came in
let's do it
chuckle I'm the second person a goose
came up one of the highlights of my trip
was visiting a Haitian elementary school
wait let's see when you I um I was sorry
when it was time to leave nukui damn
she's got skin want the alveoli then we
exchange warm goodbyes and promise to
see each other again
don't you worry don't worry I'm already
planning my next visit to Haiti new
Bobby's a pet my boy
TuneIn proponent in haiti special airing
this saturday january 27
a great show tonight break so tonight
from the new HBO series mosaic Emmy and
Golden Globe winning actress Sharon
Stone bomb we accomplice would
effectively the totally opponent but
what they know of we're see back there
okay and don't know why is translating
this part and The Hobbit Beauty and the
Beast and the nutrient Easter is the
Alienist Luke Evans ma jelly love Luke
Evans Misha Bell gasps so Misha be a
couple you sure it's opponent by him and
chameleon is Mose unsure
allelujah anybody this is you know when
keep on my blog here in this your side
let's see one see a graph slam is very
bored and of course I'll be doing my
unique brand of comedy she'll turn up
with a breaker be right back Jimmy
[Applause]
you